deep breath everyone you know good
morning it's gonna be okay hello the
morning toast I can't even speak welcome
to the morning toast this is the morning
shows could do it I don't even know how
I'm feeling I would say I'm mostly tired
yeah yeah I'm not as hungover as I
expected even though I got in bed at
3:30 in the morning
sorry my voice um how was a pizza the
bees was great yeah yes Joe's pizza so
good I mean it was cold and it was rock
hard because you know when the cheese
gets hard he just turns into like a slum
cuz it's a cool cement Club that I was
just wolfing it down and I left the
bones for Jeff
that's nice bones girl I don't really
drink eat the cross it really depends
like how [ __ ] hungry I am or what
else I'm eating like there's a pasta
dish like I'll take the crust and you
know dip it up
yeah I'll pretend like I don't eat crust
and then I find a way to yeah but I got
a person who's that can I have your
crust that's Mario or sister
oh that's Jeff he always wants to cross
I said no I would I hit a choke on it
yeah oh my god wait also speaking of
food that appetizer at last night's meal
was divine the little pasta dish receta
was that what it was called that's what
the cheese oh my god it was the best
thing I've ever had to sit down it
looked like a square piece of pizza like
from camp you know when I was like I
think serving pizza at amfAR I by the
way I thought it was a great place for
the amfAR gala last yeah sorry
let's serve in the beginning okay that's
why also I look like I'm about to go on
a jog because I told these [ __ ] I
said I'm gonna show up in my pajamas and
of course they're still cute and I'm
okay because at 9:45 as was putting my
pants on I said guys are we still doing
pajamas and you guys took so long to
answer that it would have rather been
overdressed than underdressed fine
fair okay and I don't know about like
Sookie but it's just so crazy how
anytime you go from me like the most
beautiful you've ever been yeah to then
like 12 hours later slaughter Steve ever
yeah well let me just look look like
decent no and you have to look horrible
yeah I literally I feel like like I'm
just like a bad jogger today I feel like
people are looking at me and being like
oh my god that girl's so sad like that
so tonight say about her out you know
her cage why was getting in my cab
outside of my hotel and these two girls
I thought you know when you just takes
well you're staying like a trendy fancy
AMC attorney fancy hotel but these girls
were literally talking about me and I
kind of turn
and they caught me and they were like oh
no we love your shoes cuz I'm wearing
these Ronald McDonald sneakers they're
like my like orthopedic like my god
takers you caught them catching you yes
and so I was like and they're like no we
love your sneakers and I was like you
don't like my secrets I know they look
like Ronald McDonald I was like I just
I'm so hung over email they were talking
about yeah they're talking about how
ugly my secrets I love catching people
talking [ __ ] about me yeah yeah right
and then I do what they're doing but
like more animated cuz they'll be like
and I'm just like yeah that girl yeah
we're there I did point yeah you see her
blue shirt yeah that's the one that get
her yeah yeah it was like hardcore sorry
I mean like so much and it was just like
so rude because no one's ever staring at
you in a good way you know no ever ever
ever and Ben was like what's wrong I'm
like that woman and he was like don't
always assume people are looking at you
negatively I'm like Ben you're so sweet
Ben Doc Hawking her at the bar he goes
she was looking at Instagram and she was
like my daughter's love her or something
so it actually was positive Ben nine
times out of ten people are usually like
she's the [ __ ] of course well I wanted
to recap yesterday's show really quickly
because we never got to discuss the
Jennifer and Jackie abut I'll do better
on sizing up New Jersey um I do in this
season so stressful stressful so what
we're new houses in the divide Great
Divide I don't see it anywhere I think
they're all idiots okay we'll be at
Jackie and Jennifer here and I just have
to say I was really excited to meet
Jennifer but she like blew my
expectations out of the water like I am
in love with her I want to like make out
with I want to ask her monkeys ass right
like she was so cool and so funny and
just like really self-aware and just
like didn't care you know yeah I really
liked her I knew I was gonna like her
and I I want her to come on again like
so like I want to get to know her more
on a deeper love I want to go to her
house yes and I want to use one of her
16 bathrooms also programming update
tomorrow we will have Juliet and Kelsey
Owens of siesta key I can't live the
dream crusts together that means the war
is over
whoa and I'm just really excited also a
little nervous like I wonder if she
knows like no we owe much I can file we
owe kelsey Owens and a formal apology
they're talking so much [ __ ] we should
just call this the morning apology
ya know but I'm I'm ready to grow and
evolve yes I'm ready to move to siesta
key
[ __ ] - you know what I kind of get
Florida I talk so much [ __ ] on the state
of Florida like a jet
I don't you say Florida Florida what was
here literally above it yes
Florida no it's Florida thank you from
Atlanta
yeah people from this house say Lord we
say Florida yeah you also say like
almonds or you know you say a McMahon's
pecans that's right so Ben was saying
last night how like your blessing is so
great and so American like you need a
family business yes we are coming up
with like McMahon's mayonnaise McManis
yeah but then have they really came up
with a great time Nance pecans look at
that like an old southern man yeah we're
like you go around your farm like
picking pecans yeah love it yeah even
though yeah in the South like I say
pecans people say pecans but please yeah
but you would have to say it we couldn't
care hands it's just it's a thing and
that would finally settle the debate of
how it's pronounced
right yes you use your company as a
reference yeah there we go we're solving
major world crisis today this is amazing
through the celebs that we saw last
night yes okay can we just back up real
quick though and talk about the fact
that the three of us are invited to a
basically models only party at chip
Rihanna's downtown black tie affair
black tie I am so embarrassed I took I
took an uber X out look I paid $60 to go
from like the Gramercy area downtown
just cuz I figured that I wanted to be
seen getting out of the water
it was gonna take you seriously getting
out of a Toyota Camry I literally could
take in like an old Honda Civic nobody
would have seen I got dropped off three
blocks away cuz the traffic was so bad I
got kicked off the red carpet it was a
whole thing well worth thirstier than
you because yes we also paid $80 for a
black Escalade and we waited an extra
probably 10-15 minutes on the same block
just to get chopped off right in front
yeah okay there's an you know what just
so that you know getting trapped reppin
an Escalade grants you no more respect
and done um and they too we're just
respected on the red carpet yes we just
got we got really like [ __ ] because we
we walked right after Victoria Justice
who apparently is very famous like I
know her and like I love to show on the
alodia still very themed right she's
just recognizable so I thought - you
were going crazy for her and then like
we came but like the second we started
Michelle Rodriguez a la Fast and Furious
came so we were just sandwiched between
two people who were like kind of before
and literally no one could have given
less of a [ __ ] about these short girls
on the red carpet and it was just
annoying cuz it's like they flew in all
these tall girls tracking the girls to
walk around like there was literally a
girl there who I'm 100% sure makes a
full-time salary of being Emily
Ratajkowski stunt double like dude I
thought it was her I was like I mean
Emily might have skis here and I'm like
and then I realize no it's Emily Kowski
and it was just [ __ ] like they were
just like flying in these tall girls
from Europe just to pretend to be people
just so they could outshine that the
somewhat interesting people right and
they got so much respect because they
were tall and we got no respect because
we're short so it started actually
whoring when I got shoved into the tent
so literally I was sandwiched between
like seven supermodels and then Milla
Jovovich had just come out this guy it
was in a full glitter outfit literally
pushed me to the side and then that the
red carpet later was like kind of your
necks like honey have you ever been here
and I was like no I've really never been
on a carpet before I'm not even kidding
you this was the most soul draining
soul-sucking humbling moment of my life
I get out there okay so there's a
supermodel just went I don't even know
it was some like gorgeous woman and then
they just quit taking my photo so if
you're on the red carpet they're like
snap snap set over here Heather over
here over here I got out nobody knew my
name and they usually know it's like
yeah someone walks you around no and I
had my like this like fur pashmina and
most models they have their PR person in
their manager and they can give it to
some peasant on the side though hey will
you take my purse will you take my
sweater and when you you know I'll meet
you at the end of the carpet I show up
with my grandma's shawl and then they
literally quit taking my photo and I was
standing there as they were yelling like
Mila Jovovich over here alright nobody
literally one of the camera ladies took
out her memory card suit off put it back
in and then she is alright sweetie and
took one photo because she felt so bad
because I was standing there and I said
out loud I go this is so American and
she fell back you know what I play you
know I'm gonna chuck it up to it being a
poorly organized carpet okay like you're
supposed to a babysitter who tells
people who you are like a lot of people
like how did even those photographers
okay I know they know who draw Victoria
Justices and Michelle Rodriguez but even
all of those photos like unless someone
looked like a model how would they know
who
they are like what if they're digital I
guess like no I guess it's really wait
you know I guess the photographer's
mentality is like oh this person is
probably a model I just like don't know
who they are but I'm not gonna miss
opportunity to photograph a model but I
guess they don't show up they're like no
maybe they should think how many people
are here they're interesting to look at
right no different order to get on the
carpet and you had to be somewhat
interesting yeah you had to be someone
know whatever we were raised Brian Kelly
points guy who was a sponsor of the
Vanek on us probably the best table ever
ever we were literally it was like the
chainsmokers and then like here yeah
yeah I was up the chainsmokers ass and I
didn't want to be anywhere else
yeah just sums are hot yeah they did a
great time there was Jim rock in
performance yes parson James who Jackie
reminded me his name sounded familiar
and then I remember we met him and saw
his performance at Cirque Lodge and I
just had the same experience last night
as they did at surf Lodge I'm like why
isn't he the most famous person in the
world you know he's so talented
oh the voice of an angel angel
he sounds actually like what I think I
sound like when I sing you know like a
very gospel choir like yeah how about on
preach you know but obviously I don't
sound like that or else I would have
been are we gonna do our musical I
remember last night when everybody had
like 10 tequila's and I started singing
am I really low yes America explained to
me I never realized you'd you have a low
register I have a very low register I
used to sing up and then I got really
bad nodules on my book of course you
gotta know it's pretty so yeah just so
you know Ashley Simpson that's a real
thing it's her acid reflux and so now my
voice is down here so I asked Heather
what is like your if you were to try out
on Broadway like go to an audition after
that what is like the song in a
repertoire that really both like
showcases your it's summertime by poor
game s summertime Lubin's
easy like down oh yeah oh I love it yeah
actually I I don't like watching ASMR
because I don't get the tingles maybe
then it like freaks me out but I like
doing it did um our commercial at the
Super Bowl yeah they had um Jason Momoa
stepdaughter yeah zoe kravitz zoe
kravitz almost whoa I've literally never
heard anyone refer to zoe kravitz who
was arguably more famous than her mom
and her stepdad as Jason Momoa
stepped
she's more famous than all of them
that's like that's really like I just
think of the world according to Jason
Momoa hold on ready no I gotta get a
reference that is like saying I don't
know but whatever now you can reach
Willis Bruce Willis is like third basic
daughter know anybody would be like
rumor Willis's ex stepmom as Demi Moore
yes oh yeah their mother that's her
mother
Wow way to be disrespectful is ex
stepdad Bruce Willis nope that's her
father
wait Ashton Kutcher yes rumored gamer
Willis's extant dad Ashton Kutcher yeah
yeah okay thank you okay
Kardashian over there haven't seen an
SMR beer commercial at the Superbowl and
it was so terrible
uncomfortable unless and it was from
michelob ultra hope they're not a
sponsor of the show but I was like I
used to drink make ultras in college
when I was like trying to be thin but
really when you have 75 of them there
you still had up snow late smear oh okay
Kardashians were there although we
didn't get up close and personal it was
still just like an honor to be within 10
feet of them it was an honor
Oh Kim waved at me Oh tell you yes you
don't bear witness to I bear witness
sir we're sitting like three inches
behind me so like when again I was
looking I was looking at Kim and I was
just like staring and I mean I can't you
with her smiling like the biggest smile
ever because she presented an award she
made her speech and then she gave the
award to her photographer friends and
then she took a step back and just like
looked on as they made their speech so
she had some you know big for her
eyeballs yes so I like don't realize
Heather and Jackie are like a little bit
behind me and I'm just like looking at
Kim smiling ear to ear just like and I
guess what I thought happened was like
we made eye contact and she saw me
smiling like an enormous [ __ ] freak
and she waved at me and I was like I
turn around at my guys did Kim just way
that me and they're like no because I
waved at her I I would see it smiling
like a frickin cheese sauce finally like
freaked so I realize I had her eye
contact on that so I was like so Jackie
does this little wave and of course then
I see Kim kind of like lock eyes and
then I'm behind her going like this I
was like hey Kimberly and so the Claudia
just thinks that like I can endure for
the moment but can only she now that
she was like hi-yah she waved and I was
like did she know it was really throwing
three of us out I think it looks like
usually that's we were all like sticking
out like no I think it's sunshine coming
out of my eyeballs I was like so excited
I was like literally gleaning gleaming
get what's wild we're smile was gleaming
yeah skin was beaming exactly there you
go it was so wild saying like all these
huge huge famous you know supermodels
get up there and then no one was paying
attention to the auction
but then when Kim got up there silence
and you have like you know like these
just insane cover of Vogue models trying
to snap Kim's photo I I felt like I was
in a video game
yeah like what is happening right now
she really is like another level and she
commands silence and respect yeah yeah
it was hard to quiet that room and I
gotta be honest with you mm-hmm
she is truly I can never talk [ __ ] about
how beautiful like she is truly truly
iconic Lee beautiful and photos don't do
justice now up at Ichi is she's so short
and her frame is so small and like I
just love her
yeah I'm I'm truly Courtney like I
couldn't care less about yeah and Kim
looks good from every angle like she was
wearing such a daring dress with her
very caring and very tight and she just
like looks good for my ring while also
like maintaining like a healthy body
yeah yeah have we discussed this
I can only imagine being at her level
you can't even go to you know you can't
even go to Chipotle no no you cannot
leave the house unless she is fall
glance so when I went to the Gift of
Life gala like a couple months ago where
she was being honored she actually sat
at a table for a while like trying to
enjoy the gala like with the
presentation and the guy met his donor
and like she literally had to leave like
she couldn't like people just would not
stop myself included berating her for
photos and talking and business cards
and all that [ __ ] it was like a must
be so difficult you know I mean I got
one business card last night and I could
stop talking about it it was such a well
done business card it was must have been
vistaprint must have been love is the
bread me too actually my business cards
are from vistaprint pan we have a toasty
code that I didn't use because I got it
before but when I replenish because I've
been just giving him out like hotcakes
left and right actually think I need a
redesign this guy had like his face
shaped in like a circle emoji and I
think his company was an emoji company
and you got to go get a thick
yes you gotta have the thick gloss
people won't respect you if you have
like the shitty like thin paper no yeah
you got to get like mr. Prince finest
and you need like one word on one side
of the card you know like yeah like
creative and then they cook they're like
what is she creative about you know
that's the thing you got are just
premium yeah premium it's like we're
like though like cheese it's almost like
it's like a celebrity for a photo like
that moment where you're like scared
it's also like handing your business
card to someone like it's an incredibly
thirsty thing to do and you just have to
own it you know I used to have business
cards cuz you know I've always been like
a little business lady even young and I
literally now like sometimes like you
know I'll meet people my parents age and
they're like so I want to follow your
stuff do you have a card and I'm like
you know just have your kids follow me
on Instagram because I feel like no my
dad it's someone being like I want to
follow you you have a card you have a
card that's like that person who
shouldn't be following I know speaking
of that real quick thing you did you
have to show me how to like use my phone
for good and not evil literally
yesterday you paid in the cab I felt
like an 80 year old lady going out with
y'all because y'all just have some
things on your phone I didn't know was
hex bolts stick with me I will mister
print wants you to be able to own the
now in any situation which honestly I
have a really hard time doing our
listeners are getting 500 high-quality
custom business cards Oh starting at
$9.99 use coded toast at Vistaprint calm
that is code toast at vistaprint.com
toast I'm doing that I one time made
business cards a while back and like I
was making them like me so they were
like pink with like lips on them and and
I didn't want them to have a lot of
information so I wanted to be like
Jackie serious you know email for
inquiries and it looks like a nice work
hard you know they don't harm an escort
what color was the font it was pink and
gold Oh God oh and you're like passing
them out at like every table Jack yeah
bar should all the rich men who bought
table jackieo email three increase Oh
terrible that was the big thing last
night it was just miles an enrichment
yeah and us and us bottles but never
there were some legit models Winnie
Harlow was there we met Emily didn't
Otto finally for the first time ever she
is a toaster and just like an angel from
God I would say her eyes are just like
bluer than the ocean and she just had so
much personality
yeah and she was just like real she was
like I went to this event last year
someone called me an idiot
I was like okay that's your fault on the
roller I mean Ramona we have to talk
about the Ramona of it all
okay so we're watching the chains now we
have the best sake it's not that I can't
even talk to see best seat in the house
like yeah they are performing right in
our face like his junk was right there
and then all of a sudden it's like I
thought it was like a chicken who was
like a wasted like like a barnyard
animal I could figure out what was
coming up next
only because it was like a lot of noises
yeah she's a woo girl she's a lady once
I got but like I could it was a rooster
ya know I didn't know what was about to
approach me so I turned around and then
DISA on the defense and then it was just
Ramona and a banging dress with her
heart yes oh my god
Avery was there like I said I live for
Brad it was obvious that they just like
wanted to say hi to me for my spot cuz
then they literally took my spot and I
had like the third best seat in the
house and I was actually really [ __ ]
annoyed about it cuz it happened at the
exact time Kelsey came on to sing they
did four songs in the last time they did
was their song with Kelsey and like
Kelsey's my friend and like I don't know
I just like wanted to be in the front
row but I wanted her to like see me and
like they literally push this over as
like we were getting pushed over on the
red carpet they push yeah and I wonder
if like they would have said hi and like
Ben is friendly like if we didn't get
back
yeah where they were and Ramona just
kept screaming
I'd love to chainsmokers I love them and
then I turn around I said girl you look
great and she's like oh I've seen the
change hooker so many times you know
I'll go without Avery Avery doesn't want
to go but I'll go to the show
I love the chainsmokers and I was like
you know what Ramona you do you know
true there's a lyric in one of the songs
never getting older yeah Ramona was like
we uh she kept singing the song was over
she's like we're never getting out like
no [ __ ] she was having a renaissance
last night also I'm pretty sure Avery
locked oh you know what no I'm sorry I
know what yeah no sorry no I was like
okay I don't know what you're gonna I
just move up um any other highlights
winning Harlow was there she did like a
little bit on stage and honestly it was
terrible uh with the champagne yeah it
was the whole thing was every time that
these models got up and tried they I
don't know who wrote their scripts it
just nobody was paying attention and I
looked out cuz I was wolfing down my
food all of the models you know there
was that it predominant like huge money
ya know like two of them right next to
us they were all Julie and I realized
these girls
eat all they do is jewel and that
meringue cake last night no the food
good my god oh good you guys we have to
have dinner tonight at chip Rihanna Lady
uptown one yes just because I need that
cake the cake in the pasta the pasta yes
but the cake like so let's have it you
Briana sorry they don't here for him
yeah yeah yeah they delivered the cake
and everyone was like pretty much
leaving so like we were all going to
take pictures to the bar like I thought
we were headed out so I literally took
me six [ __ ] huge bites of Jackie's
cake and ran but then we ended up coming
back to the table to enjoy our cake
where you took that wonderful photo yes
and Jackie comes just like who ate my
cake I'm like that's me don't worry
don't look at me I don't know a thousand
other cakes on the tables cuz nobody
touched her food yet okay okay good we
also just talk about the actual entree
itself oh well we got the fish because
we're kosher [ __ ] yeah it's fine it
was a very chewy
yeah just smelled bad maybe it wasn't
yeah that's why I love a smelly fish oh
god it's all better yeah yeah it was a
short rib my short rib was to die for it
was juicy it was flavorful and had a
great gravy and as the ladies started to
do is she's like you made the best
choice honey and I was like oh no I did
the potatoes are Groton were great and
then they had the nice like I was like a
cauliflower vegetable medley
delicious silly I really like now I'm in
the mood tonight I want spaghetti from
jib Brioni for dinner yeah that cake for
dessert great let's do it I ate so well
last night at the at the ball like I did
you know my something I did no I'm sorry
I eat well in terms of like I was well
fed oh no no no I was eating so much
like I forgot I was getting ID in a week
oh when you win I would have to the bar
upstairs and literally they just had
like really beautiful chipper honey
bowls that had just big blocks of
Parmesan Reggiano in there
so I legit I'm looking around and like
nobody's eating the parmesan like I can
eat this right right and you guys like
when you get a kid do you always compare
like your size of cake with everyone
else's oh absolutely it's a media when
we were walking out we walked past the
model table which had they had all left
and it had a full piece of cake on every
plate and they were so much bigger than
ours and I was thinking when I got my
cake that it looked like the end had
been my cutoff and I'm like that's a
small piece of cake and I'm like oh I
guess so just give me everyone small
pieces of cake customs models everywhere
but then I walked past model table and
they
big ass pieces like maybe they were
trying to tell me something no they
weren't trying to tell you anything they
just were probably trying to feed the
models yeah they're like she needs some
extra it was the best cake I ever had I
couldn't stop eating it it sobered me up
annoyingly but I couldn't stop I
couldn't even tell it wasn't even like a
lemon it was like almost like an almond
and then had a meringue on top it was it
was they knew it yeah I thought was a
Napoleon no I don't think it was I don't
think so either
whatever this meringue it was meringue
on top yes right well look it was just
burnt so we thought it was a marshmallow
I don't [ __ ] Alaska it was like a
baked Alaska but this ice is nasty nasty
but it looked like a baked Alaska cuz it
had so many leg it's not to review the
menu yeah you guys I think it's
ridiculous that one brother we've died
and break it down you know like what
that's the classic cherry on dessert
it's like what they're known for
is it a tiramisu my friend at least you
would know just google it yeah yeah chip
Brioni cake classic yes it's like the
Bellini of cake it was truly the most
delicious thing I ever put in my mouth
and the top was almost like you know
like fluff Marty yeah is like whipped
marshmallow fluff which I thought was I
guess meringue II it's a vanilla
meringue cake
so it's settled so I'm ordering it today
now I'm having flashbacks oh my god I
can't wait wait honestly the night never
ended because we hopped in a cab to go
to the after-party and the okay so chip
Brioni is this enormous [ __ ] place
that is on a tiny cobblestone street
it's impossible to get to and impossible
to leave on a normal night yeah but like
it was this huge event literally cars
were lined up we get into this cab and
he just didn't give a [ __ ] and he starts
literally going in Reverse on like four
blocks and you know we were in the back
like on our phones I'm gonna find our
I've got interest from the red carpet
like we were just so busy we notice and
people on the street we're looking at us
so like are you guys okay we were like
what's wrong we were like we got out of
traffic he's must have saved us over an
hour in traffic for like a three block
radius and we didn't even care or notice
and we're going backwards I I said guys
I think we're going backwards and you
thought it was like hell yeah they are
going backwards and then all of a sudden
it's like and there's an ocean
we're getting pulled over and over like
they're not was ever ago we just went
backwards for six blocks he's on a
one-way street the wrong way we're
getting pulled over so we get pulled
over and I said they're like so should
we get out and I thought it was real
police so I said no we need to be
respectful like I just don't know what
the laws are yeah
and New York is another look in a cab
it's weird I've been pulled over in a
cab form when the police come up then
usually you ask can I get out but it was
raining and we were kind of comfortable
so we did it cozy we're like you know
we'll ride this out yes I have been up
in uber Zend caps that have been pulled
over and before the cop even comes I
just hop out and it's it's a thing like
you're allowed to get out but you guys
are making me so paranoid and like the
rain and the dark like I don't know I
just did it was the rain yes like we
were really comfortable for the first
five minutes we went live on Instagram
and then it was like stupid and I was
having fun while we like weren't gonna
get into the after-party so we made we
made a Adele a dart a - yeah after 20
minutes of sitting in the cabin all you
need was your bracelet to get in - yeah
oh and then we found out that the police
that pulled us over was not actual
police it was a limousine
yeah it was taxi Limousine Commission
police like pleased that the cab driver
was very weird about it like they don't
have guns you know he had a belt of
stuff I didn't think gun but like he had
the stick you asked you were like what's
the deal and he was like oh don't worry
it's not the real police I'm just gonna
get a fine really it's not the real
police I've been saving for 20 minutes
yeah he could have told us a little
earlier on I think she enjoyed our
company I think you did you where the
[ __ ] did you get that water this is a
ten dollar water for my hotel and legit
it's a be on which is that be on a
sponsor no and honestly they should be
because they don't like that it she's
like weird milk yeah milky water but I'm
it's so thick how it comes out just like
oh my god you hear that ASMR yes when
your pizza incertum stories last night
we're really ASM Ari yes yes and Jeff
woke up and I was like is he awake I
thought it was gonna
it obviously in the middle of his sleep
that is so mad at me right now I have to
take him to lunch today why is he mad
cuz you were late yeah he was like I was
waiting up for you I would have eaten
the beets and I was like he didn't eat
the pizza nobody I have one slice for
him and then he saved me two slices but
he was very like heartbroken and I had
one of those moments where I was like
now that we're engaged I said there was
more days honey I have to go out and I
have to network and this is it and we're
on opposite schedules and it's hard but
I will make time for you and I was like
we're [ __ ] married now this would
have never happened before but now that
were engaged like you didn't come home
when you said you were going to all you
did was see me attacks
I was like I'm sorry honey I was I was
working you were I was working late babe
sorry I took it a lunch to that people
muggers are going I mean if we can get
in but I'm dressed like this so I don't
think so I don't think they care I don't
see this time indefinitely to people
this like whole conversation is making
me want to have a fat [ __ ] rich lunch
I went if I want a burger so bad with
like steak cut fries like every sauce
yeah I can't believe we've been sitting
here for 30 minutes we haven't talked
about your engagement wow oh my god and
we haven't gotten into that we spoke
about it last night but congratulations
Mazel Tov
tell us the story so it again we were
down in the Turks and Caicos at the
white Mar resort which is my favorite
place on earth I said the Gant's were
rebranded yep yeah so which is it's
always been way Morris so now it's
Jeff's way Mara which is British
it's very riche so we were in the pool
and the that resorts really special to
us because when my dad was still alive
we would always go down there vacations
together so Jeff knew that if he was
gonna propose to me like it was are
coming up on our eighth year anniversary
and I thought ring shopping in his
summer so I and I also told him like if
you don't do it soon like you're not
gonna leave this island alive like what
I know what guy was about with bricks I
met him at the fish fry yeah yeah at the
fish fry mom so he built this he built
this giant float and it was an H for my
initials I was like silk flowers and so
we're like it's like 4:30 the sun's
about to set
we're drinking margaritas in the pool
that's the time it really is Golden Hour
yes and I but I could feel like a shift
in the energy of the pool like there
were sites people knew what was about to
happen and all of a sudden people just
kinda started to float away from me and
I was having like lovely conversations
with people like Dallas and New York
conversationalist yeah yeah yeah I am I
am
you know what honestly they just kind of
float to me right I did gravitate I'm
one of those people on vacation I'd love
to make friends but I'm gonna let it
kind of come to me I'm not gonna pursue
it no then people you know they see the
face of her like she's gotta have
something to say right and she does and
she does so then all of a sudden our
favorite cabana boy put this float in
the pool and I thought it was at first I
just thought it was a drink yeah but it
wasn't and I was like you were just and
then everybody in the pool just like
backed up cuz they all knew was about to
happen and in the middle was a box with
like one of my favorite flowers in it
and so when he picked up the box
I thought the ring was gonna be in it
and I'm course I don't like surprises
like I love to surprise people but when
I get surprised I literally shut down i
black out so he picked up the box and he
had a little sweet thing about the
flower and my dad it was like this whole
thing and then I just yelled where's the
[ __ ] ring ha ha he pulled it out of
his swim trunks laying in the pool I see
this brown box coming out of his like
lacrosse shorts yes he just hopped out
of the pool and put it in but then he
went in the pool with it yes it is
dangerous could've fallen out he well no
it was in a giant box but he said he was
like I knew I had to get you in the
water
three margaritas deep or you would have
been because I who knows II I know
everything yeah yeah he's like you would
have been freaking out and like you know
aren't like I took you to dinner I took
her to sunset walk crazy too obvious so
then I see a photographer out of the
point of my uh yes ladies got a long
list but like last night you know laughs
I know so then he pulled the ring out
and I just screamed I'm a Falcons wife
because we have a couple friends whose
husbands playing the Falcons in Atlanta
and I told Jeff I was like Jeff you know
we lit ring-shopping and I was like I
picked out a lot of things I said listen
I just want you to make me feel like an
NFL wife I want they're reasonable very
reasonable and so when I saw the ring I
just screamed I'm a Falcons wife now can
we get a zoom Jake on her ring it is
beautiful you are an NFL and it is so
unique thank you you know you're never
gonna find someone with that ring and
that's that's the operative part why
picked out this setting from Jeff's
jeweler HNH jewelry in New York and and
I saw this with a different stone and
then I said hey can we put a diamond it
like yeah we can't girl nice yeah that's
young so now you have two weeks how did
you feel different I do it a little
different people said it changes I feel
like I wrote like I got my old
ball-and-chain now I looked at it again
sir there you go oh geez I really have
to go through with this he's like it
you've been in an eight years totally
like you already have a plant right
Italy Italy me and Jackie will be there
yeah I've never been you think no not
Capri we're gonna do Tuscany Rick yeah
better pasta better pasta I'm more of a
you know Tuscan countryside driving a
Fiat yes scarf around my neck and some
beautiful glass sauce I will gladly
partake if I couldn't just have one
across as a way I guess I want like
never any pasta Oh done it does probably
about six yeah we and I want to do it
like family-style where it's like
everyone's that like one long-term yeah
and you just have like insane food is
chicken and pasta and I'll make balls or
whatever you know I'd everyone goes to
Capri but here's the thing Capri there's
no time of year where it's not just
touristy as [ __ ] so I like being in
Tuscany Villa moment oh my god yes very
like orange and green vibes and I was
laughing I was like what have we yet
given everybody to come to Italy and
tell them they're staying in a castle
then it's like a fire fest
and we're just like so let's do it let's
do it fire fest Italy 2020 2020 okay
Italian toasters oh wait garlic bread
that's funny
that's honey okay there is start a group
it is now time to get into the past
forth stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
look consider that really nothing
happened and our first story was amfAR
recap cuz we're gonna give you a better
recap than any of these news outlets you
know oh yeah no we'll tell you what
really happened we'll tell you what was
for dessert yeah right the delicious my
way and there was a cookie plate that
was also real yeah yeah some story right
and Ben Ben and I were just housing
those little fruit things what it was
like a custard it was like a graham
cracker with a custard and then a fruit
on top I have to talk to him about it
I'm the play and I was like thanks man
for the heads-up papi nothing if not
generous you know Jeffy yes so just
heart okay first story Halley Bieber and
Justin Bieber are sharing the cover of
this month's vogue
mr. and mrs. Bieber basically share
wardrobe Justin Bieber and Haley Baldwin
Bieber share a sense of style that's
always been in lockstep and now they've
proven their love of a twinning moment
inside the pages of Vogue the newlywed
couple appears on the cover of the
magazine's 2019 issue shot by Annie
Leibovitz in the cover image the pop
star wearing only do our home a shorts
cradles his bride clad in a white
embellished Prada dress but the inside
pages is where the Bieber's really show
off their love of a matching achi look
in one shot they even go as far as to
split a pair of Dolce about Gabbana
polkadot pajamas with Haley wearing the
oversized top and a matching bikini and
Justin wearing the bottoms okay so okay
so what I got from this Jeff and I could
share is New York giant sweats yeah I
don't ever know I hate them couple oh my
god no meet you and you know me and my
big ring right now like I'm Chuck
wearing Heather saying we have the same
size we do if it's like a glitter like
Heather I'm gonna get right my fingers
are sausages 'ice well so that would not
drink yeah which I it's so pretty I
don't think wearing the same sized
clothes as your husband is a great thing
about save I do want to say like at one
point in time I did wear men's clothes
and you know what it was a dark time to
it yes yeah you know ooh
it's really nice feels good right bling
City length fit a bit that is nice
well I think there's a couple other
things I would like to harp on in terms
of the article not that they were the
same size clothes because like that's
just a satin like makes me feel bad but
they talked a lot about sex
Justin was celibate for like a year and
a half because he was very much a sex
addict
really yeah and it was really important
to him and he was checking up Jesus
would you say how do you know no I just
really enjoy sex
I think but like you're supposed to yeah
no I think there were all those stories
about him like I think he was like
engaging in like lewd behavior oh gotta
go you know yeah and there was a couple
other things like the he was saying he
actually sounded very sober
okay and he said that being a sex addict
like that was his last vice that he
hadn't gotten rid of I think implying
that like he did struggle otherwise with
addiction which was very brave of him to
discuss which if you become a huge star
you know eight years old right did you
see anyone doing drugs last night no I
did not know just Julie yeah well I was
like in the bathroom like giving ever on
side I'm like what has ever run off to
in here I need any heroin needles I
gotta get it off you know okay do you
remember we were in the bathroom and I
literally like took off my dress amazing
I was like Claudia you got to help me
pull my Spanx yeah and there's a tiny
thin woman I couldn't tell if she was
like she was trying to be like Royal
Saudi or yeah oh my god she was so
shouting walked in and she goes she's
like laughs oh I'm gonna go into the
stall to fill up mine and I looked at
you and she had a cutout dress like
literally the size I'm wearing she wants
a wearing Spanx we would have seen a
because my Spanx tuck right underneath
it might so yeah that you know me and
Heather literally like had our dresses
my spacing to be readjusted up here and
how they're broad needed to be
readjusted like we were just like
shameless we're in the bathroom I cook
Karen is when we came she's oh I'm gonna
go into the stall and and I just said
you want to go get more cake I cannot no
it was [ __ ] so you get a Halley and
Justin yeah I actually the article
actually made me like them and like she
said right when we got married I had so
much anxiety cuz like literally I just
made like a million enemies for no
reason because people were just like
especially online like waiting for us to
fail and like I she was literally
talking directly to me so I wanted to
apologize yes and the proof is in the
pudding they've been together for a
while and I'd like at Laos to outlasted
Pete and Ariana they are more I guess
they're equally legitimate to Nick and
Priyanka except they weren't so extra
about their wedding you know they were
there's no private and that makes it
more legit in Maya Arlo Thank You
Brianna fans are known with our nation's
youngest skeptics I know there's
something about it I really want to
believe in that love because my mom was
11 years older than my late father so I
love an older woman young she don't even
realize yeah but yeah she's like like
yeah yeah and he's my age that's crazy
how would you feel if your father were
in your own age so I but I don't know
but I kind of hear that it's not I'm
here weren't you I just wish they went
about it in a different way
the thirst with like all the videos that
pictures the Bogue that this it like
never ended yeah you're right I'm to
people who are as big as stars as they
are like usually command more privacy
like Haley and Nick
I mean Halley and Justin they're like
thirst monster Instagram whatever and
even they are so private like I know
nothing about that and like everything
everything I see about them in the press
wasn't released by them it's like a
paparazzi who caught the him crying on
the beach like everything in beige it
was like put out by them and it's weird
yeah yeah it was weird that the people
mag and then they had like it is another
wedding last week in New Jersey yeah
another one is for friends and family in
New Jersey who couldn't make it it's
like it never ends 11:11 make-a-wish
meringue cake meringue cake meringue
cake meringue cake meringue caper and
cake meringue and see that's pretty good
I ready for next story great something
that we haven't discussed yet but it's
been all over Instagram and I don't
really care but a lot of people send it
to me the bachelors Cassie Randolph
addresses docu-series that's currently
airing about her and her ex okay and
this is really Shady well and I saw the
story developing and it wasn't until he
really sat down and read it till I
realized how shady it was okay this is
the long story short Cassie was a
student at a Christian college
so is Heather M who's also on The
Bachelor they were filming a show a
siesta key type show in their college I
think it was like a student project like
it wasn't on any networks I think it's
like you know someone's passion project
and they're making like a cool little
shot we're like someone who's like
studying film yes but the way that it's
happening to make it look like a TV show
but I don't think it was on any TV
networks and it follows her and her
friends and you know she's on and off
again with her boyfriend so now she's on
The Bachelor competing for Colton and
really and winning Colton and these
trailers for this show are coming up on
Instagram and people it looks like she's
a thirst monster who's just like on
every reality TV show however I think
this was filmed a while back her and her
man broke up for good before she went on
The Bachelor oh god that they broke up
for good like a week before shortly
right and then she's on The Bachelor so
it looks shady then I saw a post by her
ex-boyfriend who wrote like Cassie can't
really speak for herself right now
because Bachelor people aren't allowed
to do press while they're still trust us
we've sure but he said like things were
very much over between the two of us
like she's a great girl I have nothing
bad to say and like you
can't plan like what happens in your
life if I had met like the one a week
after Cassie and I broke up like that's
how it was just meant to be so like I
totally respect her going on The
Bachelor he was like that was the
decision that really finalized our
breakup because they couldn't decide for
awhile
well this just sounds really normal to
me but people are trying to make her
look like a thirst monster you know
she released a statement and said I'm
getting a lot of questions about my ex
and a docu-series oh no I'm sorry yeah
and the doctor series we filmed before
the bachelor well I don't feel it is
necessary that I share all the details a
lot of people are curious and the worst
thing is false rumors I didn't want to
address this without permission but he
posted about it today so I think it's
good if I do to Kaitlyn and I dated all
through college and in 2015 we filmed
young ones 2015 a while after our
breakup we put our past behind us and
became friends again we share a lot of
mutual friends and he is close to my
family we both needed other people and
and moved on while we were never
officially a couple again there was a
time last spring that we consider
getting back together but that didn't
work out I was open to saying friends
but he understandably thought this was
too hard just because we didn't work out
doesn't mean we now hate each other and
don't care about each other
I just wasn't right for us since I was
the one saying we couldn't be together
this was extra hard for him
relationships are complicated navigating
isn't usually straightforward we were on
and off for so long that turning into
turning it on for good was a difficult
decision as I truly didn't want to
regret giving up on the three were meant
to be oh my god just reading the
statement if I didn't know who Cassie
was I know this Taemin I'm like oh she's
pretty in skidding you know did you know
what I mean like I've never liked that
made me like really lightheaded I'm not
I don't know he truly it made me light
edit maybe tired really just like
whizzed through how did you guys like
the auctioneer what not that guy was
really like thirsting it up for he made
some good money for amfAR last night you
know it was on the name of a good cause
it was but he was thirsty as hell we
relate every story back to amfAR because
I was like judging went to the event of
do not have been there yeah and we got
it's really why because I we were
literally like no actually actually I
take back that statement we deserve to
be there and I'm gonna tell you right
now all those people on the red carpet
who didn't want to take my photo thank
you to the one woman yeah you yes so one
woman
her name's probably Leslie and she
looked at me and she goes sweetheart
I'll take your photo yeah no she was
nice I know exactly your talk about
yours in the front right yeah yeah yes
am i late we did deserve to be there no
one enjoyed themselves
nobody more no one drank France no more
dance more no one smiled more no one
networked more now should I really get
up no way Jack him more no no Kim waves
and nobody more exactly so we really
deserves we are in a strike I feel like
we really knew were like the motivators
they bring to bar mitzvahs like we
really enhance the night for others yeah
yes and for ourselves yeah really set
the tone yeah I feel always that way but
then it's like is that what they want
you know I don't do they want it to be
like nose in the air yeah good question
I don't know I don't know so we all into
the bachelor terrible it's not it's
worse I've never watched a single
episode yeah I'm jealous of all the time
they never counted it yeah as your round
I didn't don't yeah they don't worth it
but I like Cassie and I didn't need an
explanation for this little show that
her student film friend filmed the
toasters made it a story and the way
that her ex-boyfriend spoke about her
was very kind and tells me everything I
need to know about her as person I agree
not a vindictive and also they were like
it's her college boyfriend she's not in
grad school like [ __ ] has no job yeah
what we should do the thing yeah I'm
over it like I think and what the ex
said was like the the TV show the
docu-series is posting on these trailers
now in a very you know strategic way
because that she's on the show and
they're trying to like they're trying to
get some viewers on their fake streaming
service and it worked okay this next
story goes back to something we were
talking about yesterday and we were with
TV G last night so I would be curious to
get his take on it but it is more some
more aviation in Birds strike planes in
the USA
more than 40 times a day faad to show so
a sulli situation is happening 40 times
a day ten years after a collision with
Canada geese force airline pilot Chesley
Sully Sullenberger to make his dramatic
emergency landing on the Hudson pilots
and airports report as many bird strikes
as ever civilian flights based in the
USA reported fourteen thousand six
hundred and sixty one collisions with
wildlife in 2018 a USA Today analysis of
faad2 shows that's more than 40 a day
tying the previous year's record the
strikes have been blamed in more than
one hundred and six civilian deaths
worldwide over the past two decades
according to British and Canadian
research
they caused about 1.2 billion dollars a
year in damage well can't revive what's
that movie where the guy is like thing
is like Sully wasn't a hero the planes
are built is it Dennis from 30 rock mmm
no it's a movie where the guy like he's
looking like he finally knows he meets
his woman cuz like she also thinks like
Sully's not a hero like the plane did it
not Sully oh I don't know
[ __ ] oh my god it's really bothering me
I'm Sheryl write in the comments um yes
I mean this just goes back to what I'm
saying today like you call them pilots I
call them bird murderers it's terrible
and you know what justice for the birds
and so we're so gluttonous and we're so
trying to get somewhere like we always
just have like a place to be and it's
like at what cost
this cost 4,000 birds I'll take a bird
any diem day birds or sky rats okay
PETA don't come at me yeah I mean you
walk through the streets of New York
dude those things are carrying all sorts
of [ __ ] and they attack you they do I
wanna hear something so interesting I
was in Mexico and I was at the hotel I
kept seeing like there was three or four
people standing on the beach and like
the pool area with literal hawks on
their arms though chained and I'm like
that is so terrible like I said the
tourist attraction you're gonna get
someone to take a picture with a hawk
like a hawk isn't deadly and like let
him fly then I found out they're
actually there to scare off other like
birds and pigeons on the beach like that
are always eating your food and then I
think I thought I'm like the whole
weekend I didn't see a bird so I didn't
know how to feel about it cuz like I was
kind of grateful that there were but
this is like bird slavery right it was
terrible
he had a chain they just let the Hawks
like fly around and keep them out or
what do you then oh no then you'd get
attached by a heart or like the Hawks
wouldn't be interested in the beach and
they'd go elsewhere and like then they'd
have to defend yourselves yeah where
they got this a real double-edged sword
yeah it was a particularly at first I
felt so sad and then I realized they
were useful and I'm like hmm
I'm selfishly now into this idea cuz
birds on the beach are so [ __ ] in a
way so annoying they always eat your
fries yeah it's my job that's yeah see I
wanted to get your guys's opinion that's
that's bit conflicting yeah here's my
thing the birds like I obviously
to share this face you know here in the
area the air so I mean I'm just glad I'm
not getting like sucked out of an
airplane right right that's our biggest
like in in 2019 like these are still
things we have to think about also
here's the thing if that many people are
getting that many planes getting hit by
Birds
clearly they're just getting hit and
going yeah I don't I mean it's not
actually going into like that the engine
of it all well it's not affecting
illicitly
sir I try to use my words but I'm still
looking from the marina yeah there are
several factors that are increasing this
which is changing migratory patterns
bigger and faster and quieter
turbofan-powered aircrafts which are
giving birds last time to get out of the
way oh we're literally invading their
space if you see a big weekend we are
terrorists we're literally going up
behind them yeah like on the street and
quietly this second about yeah like it's
their space like we are not meant to be
30,000 feet and we're going up there
invading their habitat and killing their
families it's terrible it's not right
it's not right okay now to make matters
worse we call airplanes birds just to
put a little salt in the wound
metaphorically terrible terrible travel
okay
well if they maybe fix the trains we
could take trains but you know Europe
doesn't well but the infrastructure in
America is such [ __ ] yeah you should be
able to take a train from LA to New York
like okay and not get a pin but like how
fragile right
Margeaux fish my friend her husband took
a train from New York to LA because he
had to get surgery or something he
couldn't be on the airplane and it was
two days and Margo like the whole two
days was freaked out she didn't go with
him she was freaking out it isn't so bad
oh my god on a train on a car where you
don't move that's horrible
yeah my worst nightmare two full days
even like in the fancy cart with the
shower but yeah I don't know if there's
a restaurant I would really love it
though if they brought trains back and
like you could slam restrains Lam trains
like Harry Potter trains yeah yeah me
too grains yeah I mean I love sitting
down so yeah yeah and you know you have
service your Wi-Fi you're not liking
yeah maybe there's like a cute boy
there's no birds startup startup inter
bored broken-down service oh yeah the
pods like Delta one yeah the training no
it would need to be nicer if I'm there
for two days and you can see you could
go through like Wyoming you could like
see things like I want to spend that
whole part of the world but I just it's
like you know that Netflix has a movie
that's just a train ride from like
Bergen to Oslo and you just watch like a
four-hour train ride
that's like stoners yeah that's Netflix
and toke yeah what's that
you took the old word you take it - oh I
never heard that I heard you take a rip
a puff you inhaled Hren let me tell you
back in my day he's saying take a choke
I didn't I'm in my 30s
okay last story JC Penney is ditching
appliances and most furnitures from its
stores it's time it's they should also
just just employees
yeah yeah just come on JC Penney JC
Penney is trying to reinvent itself
again it's getting rid of appliances and
most furniture to return its focus to
clothing sales the company hasn't turned
a profit since 2010 and it forecasts
several more years of losses new CEO
Jill sills how pledged quote quick
action to put JC Penney on the path to
profitability
explain to me JC Penney hasn't been
profitable in 2010 but last year they
did this whole thing with influencers
Jacques Pinay and they literally paid
influencers upwards of $15,000 maybe
that's why they're in the tank shock
that was a good idea that they like
wanted to do like a fancy store so they
made a shock been a JC Daniel it didn't
like tertiary fraternity right right
[ __ ] love toys a thing JC Penney
doesn't have any good brands in it
nobody's it's like like like what does
JC Penney needs me that I can't get what
are they sells yeah they were selling
appliances and now clothes but they're
taking out like all the kitchen stuff so
it's gonna be a clothing store I
literally didn't even know you could buy
a microwave at JC Penney I thought it
was just a JC Penney no I'd already
thought it was just a retail store like
for clothes I guess it's going back to
what I already thought it was oh it's
like no but it's like old school Sears
you know I back in the day you should go
to Sears to keep washer/dryer oh yeah
even what I think of Sears I think
appliance I don't think t-shirts yeah
this is the problem they need
because when I think of JCPenney and
clothing I think more like TJ Maxx like
I would they need just a new name it's a
terrible name maybe they should call it
but there it seems like just like penne
and then it sounds like a cheap story
get something yeah oh yeah yeah look at
that like a dollar store just uh they
could ACP know when it comes to I like
HPV yeah and also when it comes to like
having names of stores be like initials
it's never good yeah BJ's what do I sell
at BJ's I've actually never been I think
it's like Walmart I think it's tedious
right at BJ's like super short yeah it's
like a like a shitty Sam's Club but I
don't know Tim's Club they don't have
any all right like it okay seems like a
shitty Costco oh I scoffs go Jays very
cool for electronics but I'm pretty yeah
it's Costco's King then seems the Tim
BJ's got it okay yeah it is then Walmart
oh but I like Walmart I like one more -
yeah price match guarantee are you
really go away and price matching [ __ ]
Claudia
Oh for like a TV yeah roll over lay over
layaway no I don't I was gonna go south
so I don't like Walmart's and I can say
that okay what do you like why don't you
why don't people J oh why don't people
from the south like Walmart you know I'm
sure people in this house do like
Walmart I just don't like it because
where when I went to school in
Mississippi that was our only store like
our only big store was the Walmart and I
was just like would be peasant like
where's charge a note I mean target is
literally the greatest store on earth
it's just you know what I don't like a
lot of tchotchkes when I go to Walmart I
get a lot of a lot of tchotchkes
I agree but you can't get anything you
need okay this is true was that our last
story how was our last story wow I feel
refreshed
anything else no I just like really have
to be I'm so hungry
where we going to lunch oh you have to
go I have to know I'm starving and I'm
slightly hungover so yes so - that's a
great reason and way to end ladies and
gentlemen it has been an absolute
pleasure hanging out with you make sure
you are tuned in tomorrow we have Juliet
Porter and Kelsey Owens from fiesta key
team easy honest I'll be here
oh really yeah I might have to go to the
courthouse that's not going to the
you can't be here I might have into a
coma I might have to get married
tomorrow gonna get married
um but Matt we like I obviously want to
come now first yes tacky but the last
time I didn't go to the courthouse
because of a guest on the toaster really
bit me in the ass yeah no it's
interfering with our vacation it's a
whole thing
Thank You Heather for being here do you
guys make me keep up with Heather on her
Instagram Heather McMahon came in
Twitter - Ian is that what it said to
her no it's Kyle my middle name but when
I tell people on the phone cuz they
never can smell my nose I'm like yeah
it's Heather
hey like her - Jen MacMahon yeah like oh
and then they actually perk up because I
think I'm a Kardashian but I'm like no
it's I'm just
it's Heather McMahon taken know but I
just I it's always gonna have okay I
like it
Jim move to have - McMahon no be you do
you Heather Kyle ooh
if you really like one it's like wear
fedoras and stuff yeah you can be
Heather Heather Brown yeah when I double
that's a really nice name like Fernando
answer
thank you Paul another Kyle yeah me Joe
oh yeah the girl she's so pretty she's
amazing style have you seen her thin
ankles she has a really thick neck also
that one photo that they did take our
Getty Images my neck is so thick that's
just like my life thick neck thin ankles
see you later [ __ ] guys love you
we'll see tomorrow
you